Hello.
I am off center. Sorry. I was talking
to Ben behind the scenes. Hello, all. Welcome
back to the
there. Hello, all. Welcome back to Rawkode Academy.
Today's session, we are taking a look at
Teleport nine, which has just been released. You
may have seen the release announcement yesterday.
Two days ago? Yesterday. Yeah. Yesterday. With some
awesome new features. So we thought we would
jump onto a session and take a look
at the new features and also do a
bit of a q and a. So if
you have any questions, please feel free to
get involved, drop them into the comments, and
we'll tackle them. Well, I won't tackle them.
I'll do my best. But we are joined
today, fortunately,
by, to the loo,
Ben Abbott. Hey, man. How's it going?
It's good. Thanks for having me, David. I
know. I'm I'm gonna be tweaking my position
trying to make sure that I'm I'm centered.
I know.
So thank you for joining us again. This
is not our our first stream together. We
always have a lot of fun playing with
Teleport together, and I'm sure today will be
no exception.
For the people that have not seen you
before on the the livestream here, can you
just tell us a little bit about Ben?
Yeah.
My name is Ben Arendt. I'm a developer
relations manager at Teleport, and I've been in
the developer tool space, I think, almost like
a decade now in various roles,
spanning UX product and developer relations.
And so
I've sort of touched everything. I also ran
a Redis as a service product. And so
I'm pretty excited about our Redis support since
when
we had Redis to go, many people would
find their passwords in GitHub.
And so
which is a common thing. No. There's nothing
too bad in your Redis database,
but it's not something you wanna expose.
And so, yeah, I'm excited to demo Teleport
nine, our machine ID, and the long tail
of other things we've added.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
It feels like there's just a new release
of Teleport
every other week. And of course there's not
a new release every other week, but for
a company and a team, user moving really,
really fast. It's just so exciting to see
all these new features coming along. I think
I've completely just bought into the Teleport eFalls
now and I just use it
constantly.
And the fact that we're getting new features
on a regular is just great.
Now, so that I don't mess it up,
what is the official release cadence? Do you
have one Or is it just when something's
cool is built, we're gonna ship it?
No. I think we've moved to a three
month release cycle. Three month. And we also
made our roadmap public. And so you can
go to our docs and see what our
roadmap is for the next three months. We
also changed our semantic versioning
last year to sort of represent
more breaking changes between the different versions and
version compatibility.
There was sort of a time in which
we wouldn't like, we would ship lots of
features, but we wouldn't change the version or
our version wasn't very clear.
So another thing since we're, an open call
company,
we have a request for discussion. And so
you can go to our Git repo and
sort of understand, like, what our, like, versioning
strategy is and then also look at our
road map. And
the one feedback we've got is, like, it's
great that you're releasing all these features, but
upgrades can be difficult, especially for, like, our
large customers.
And that is something that is going to
be added in,
I believe, Teleport 10, maybe 11. But there's
a team actively working on sort of automatic
upgrades,
which is an interesting, you know, computer science
problem in itself.
Yeah. Definitely.
Well,
I think I've been using Teleport and Cluster
now for, like, eighteen months. In fact, starting
with Teleport five, and we're now at Teleport
nine.
And it's always auto installed the latest version,
but at no point has it ever broken
my automation. Like, we always just seem to
get a new version of Teleport, and it
just works. Like, I mean, half their backwards
compatibility breaks, and I've just been very lucky?
Or,
like
I think it's mostly some of our customers
who may be on four or five. Alright.
Okay. You know, also because we have a
whole,
you know, large suite of customers from, like,
open source community to sort of, like, Fortune
five hundreds. You know, we've still supports
like, we supported Center West 6 longer than
Center West 6 was sort of
supported by Red Hat. And so we generally
try to, like, meet our customers where they
are. And you might see sometimes in our
releases, we do do
back patches to I think you're you're going
back to, like, six for both performance and
security. And you can see that in our,
like, semantic versioning we describe, like, at what
point will we, like, not back port security
fixes. But if it's a bad one, we
will sort of go about our way to
back port one. I think we backported a
fix into,
like, four dot something recently.
So we try and support all of our
customers as much as we can. That's awesome.
Cool.
Alright. Well, we're here today to talk about
the latest release, Teleport nine, which dropped yesterday.
Do you wanna give us the the highlights
of the release so that we can dig
into a few of them? I can pop
the blog up if you wanna start on
Machine ID, or do wanna start with just
a high level No. Let's start on Machine
ID. Okay. Go for it. So
machine ID is a new addition to
Teleport nine,
and we sort of described the problem in
this blog post. But,
you know, up until
Teleport nine, like Teleport nine, Teleport was mainly
focused on sort of humans accessing infrastructure
and being really good at that. But we
would have people who would set up all
of their infrastructure with Teleport, you know, maybe
not even have, like, open SSH.
And then we want to also use the
same short lived certificates for, like, Ansible runs
for Jenkins. Basically, everything that also has some
form, like, SSH certificates to some degree.
And you could do this with Teleport. You
could do, like, TCL auth exports,
asserts
for a short period of time. But people
would just end out making these, like, five
year SSH certificates,
which is basically the same as like a
public private key to some degree. Yep.
And,
you know, in Teleport, we have a CA
rotation that you can run. So
if you did a CA rotation,
that long lived certificate would break.
And then
all of that, like, other work that people
like, when we had teams kinda build this
in house, and so machine ID is a
sort of a new addition to
sort of Teleport that makes it very easy
for you to issue sort of certificates and
identity for machines
and
sort of provide that same tooling for, infrastructure
tools.
I imagine for people that were doing this
prior to machine ID, especially when they're using
one of the, you know, OpenID or back
ends and not local users, which I assume
is probably a large majority of Teleport customers.
But they would probably have to break out
to local users for machines.
Is that a fair assumption?
They could. We also added impersonation.
And so you could create a u like
a non login user
that you could impersonate,
and that was sort of our recommended approach
to this. But,
yeah, some people would create like a local
user. Because you ultimately don't want someone to
be able to like physically log in as
the Jenkins bot person.
True. That makes a lot of sense. So
machine ID is is gonna solve this challenge
for people that wanna be able to get
their CI systems access to the infrastructure. Yeah.
So, you know, we'll focus a lot on,
like, infrastructure tooling. It's just probably our strongest
thing in Teleport nine. But in nine point
one, we extend
the same short lived certificates for database access,
Kubernetes,
and applications.
And
as you may know, in
our current configuration of Teleport for Kubernetes,
you actually have to issue a very long
join token because
the
it doesn't persist the connection. So we plan
to use machine ID to issue the cube
configs and always keep your cube config and
the connection between, like, Teleport and your Kubernetes
cluster always updated and secure.
Alright. Awesome. Oh, we
we just got a question from Evanash. He's
just joined and is curious if the concept
of machine ID has been explained yet. So
we're we're talking about it right now, Evanash.
But I'll patterface that and think or write
down if I got wrong. Yeah. That's a
good idea.
I wouldn't be able explain it twice unless
I've just completely fluffed it and misunderstood that
away. But, you know, the
what Teleport has done really, really well today
is
when humans want access to infrastructure because let's
face it, humans are the security problem anyway,
that they go through Teleport and authenticate as
a human, and then you get federated access
to servers and databases.
The challenge there has been that if you
want to give Jenkins,
GitHub actions, or any automation
access to any of these resources, which are
being
commoditized. I don't even know if that's the
right word, commoditized or secured via Teleport.
People would have to do some weird things
there. Now
in the past, I've just used local users
and breaking out of that entire control flow
and saying this works, which is usually bad
practice. Ben mentioned that there's also impersonation and
Teleport, but that is then using user authentications
to pretend to be another role within the
Teleport ecosystem,
which works well. But
this new concept, machine ID, allows machines and
automation processes to become first class citizens within
the Teleport authentication workflow
and give them access to the same resources
in a secure fashion.
Does that work? I think that's a great
summary.
Awesome. I was really terrified I was gonna
make an answer to that. But we're
So do you wanna tell us a little
bit about I'm curious of how machine ID
works from
setting up and getting started. And I we
will have demos, but maybe we could talk
about at a high level. How does it
work into the flow that we have now?
And how does it work under the covers
if we're willing to kinda go into a
little bit of detail there as well?
Yes. So at a high level,
you know, I think
where where to begin for the high level?
So we have a T Bot service. And
so when you install Teleport, now there's like
a fourth binary called T Bot.
And T Bot is the service that you
will issue on, let's say, your Ansible control
node.
And you
sort of enroll Tbots
in the same way in which you'd enroll
Teleport nodes,
either through, like, an ephemeral join token or
IAM token join method.
I would actually recommend well, we've, like, focused
most of our sort of UX around the
AWS token join method, which means you don't
need to share any secrets.
You just give it a
basically, as long as the machine has the
a role identity, it can automatically join the
cluster.
And then you scope your access in the
same way in which you'd use Teleport roles.
So you just use another role, and the
role says, you can access these like, this
machine can access these hosts, say, like, Jenkins
hyphen star,
and they can do the like, these commands.
And then if you're in your application
for
it has some, like, handy other features. So
for SSH configs, it, like, automatically creates an
SSH config for you.
So I'll do a Ansible example, and you'll
see it just more or less works sort
of out of the box. You don't need
to make any of the other changes.
And let's say if you're
like, when we add database support, you just
sort of change your
setup to use
the three certificates
for TLS connections
as opposed to, let's say, like, the password
for your Postgres database.
Okay.
So I didn't know that I hooked in
to so that's just you can use AWS
kind of workload identity to be able to
speak to Teleport.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's I think we added
it in, like, seven, but there's a IAM
join method. And so you just give you
create a token
that says,
this token can join with this role.
And as long as it has the identity
document from this account, you can automatically join
the account.
And does this
does this change anything for the operator side
of Teleport? Do they do I need to
do anything different when deploying Teleport? Or is
this just something that I get out of
the box by default for free with any
Teleport,
like an app upgrade or an app install?
Yeah. You just get it for free. You
might have to change, like, the token type.
But as long as you're in Amazon so,
like, what people were doing is, like, let's
say it's like the big strapping your trust
problem.
And so
Teleport
has, like, a range of different tokens. So
I think get the sort of least secure,
you just do, like, a hard coded string,
which is probably our least secure version. Then
you can do a issue like t cuddle,
like, nodes join or cube join.
Then that's like a short lived join token.
And some people would publish those tokens to,
like, secret store. And then when you bootstrap
the host, it would, like, go to secret
store, download the join token, and then it
would join.
In this way, you don't need to do
any of that other kind like, machinery. You
can just use the IAM join method for
your notes, for example, or for T Bot
in this case.
Okay.
What about for people that are not on
AWS? Is this something that you think will
be rolled out to, like, Google's version of
workload identity or Azure's or whatever people on
bare metal? Do they have any options to
be able to look into this machine ID
concept?
We'll probably look into the other cloud providers.
You know, GCP and Azure have the same,
like, identity documents available on the hosts.
But for bare metal, you sort of have
to build your own
trust of what the machines are.
That doesn't sound scary at all. Right? I
mean, I guess in theory, you know, that,
like,
the pro like, historically,
like, you go to the rack, you see
that machine, you'd like, okay. I trust this
machine. But in the cloud, you don't know
necessarily that that new machine that fired up
is, like, your machine or not.
Yeah. That makes sense. And there's, like, another
interesting project like, SOPs was a project from
Azita Yeah. For encrypting your, like, ENV. And
they use the same sort of
method for encrypting their tokens using a sort
of a KMS key based upon, like, the
identity documents.
Okay. Cool.
But this is like a whole rabbit hole
of actually, I a webinar on, like, cool
tokens, TLS, and Teleport,
which is sort of deep dive into all
of the different ways in which you can
set up and configure tokens.
And it's a fun topic, but it's it's
also, like, quite day two operations.
But day two happens to be all the
other days after you set up Teleport, so
it is important.
Okay.
What are some of the
the primary use cases then for people to
start rolling out or using machine ID?
I think infrastructure tooling.
I have a good demo for Ansible and
then also for Jenkins.
Just these tools that you've had around in
which you've had to provide them SSH certificates
or access
for a period of time,
but
you
haven't rotate like, you you might have created
a public private key and you haven't really
rotated it that often. Yeah. And I think,
you know, we've seen more
supply chain attacks that have gone through CICD
build servers, and I think it's sort of
the area in which people are paying more
attention to. So that's probably where we would
start. I think the next one will be
adding support for databases
and sort of applications and Kubernetes clusters, but,
that support is in 9.1.
Alright. Awesome. Another use case is if you
wanna interact with the Teleport API, you can
use T bot to get a certificate that
will talk to the Teleport API as well.
Okay. So, I mean, I don't know what
your Ansible demo is, but let me guess.
And then you could you can walk us
through it. So when I think of Ansible,
I think about
a human typically running an Ansible playbook, which
has a inventory fail, but allows it to
go and speak to one or more machines.
I'm assuming your demo is gonna be, well,
what if I wanna automate running an Ansible
playbook and I have to machine do that
without the human component there? I'm assuming Ansible
is gonna request
some sort of ephemeral
SSH token to go onto all the machines
to run the playbook,
Or is that just way off the mark?
It's pretty close. I think the thing that's
different is it's more or less the same.
And Teleport or, like, machine ID does everything
for you. So you don't need to worry
about
certificates and access, SSH config, actually generates it
all for you. So maybe just a demo
would be the easiest way to kinda, like,
show you. Yeah. Let's take a look. Sounds
good. Okay.
Share my screen.
Alright. Your screen is now shared.
I can see a terminal, and I can
see GitHub login for Teleport.
Yeah. We have this sort of diagram, which
I'll kinda come back to it.
But this is sort of what I'll walk
through. So we have Teleport deployed.
We have a Ansible control node, and we
have a group of sort of EC two
servers that we've added that it can
connect to. And like I said, this machine
ID is joined using the IAM join method.
And they actually these credentials for the SSH
config are rotated every twenty minutes
Okay.
Which is sort of a cool feature that
sort of happens out of the box. And
there's other security features like you can lock
hosts,
SSO in.
So much multifactor.
Yep. Every time.
Oh, and my password.
I have a blog post called why SSO
sucks, and you can see why. This is
my daily experience.
Okay. So, you know, here's Teleport. You know,
people are familiar. It's just, like, a list
of all of the servers and hosts.
You don't necessarily have to like this machine
ID
service has, like, Teleport and machine ID just
for this sort of demo purposes
to make it easy to access.
And
I have a Ansible playbook. So let's just
so the
my playbook,
very simple. It just
all hosts, the user, it just pings host
name. So
Let me just run it.
Oh, no. Okay.
So some of these ones haven't connected. And,
actually, there's a reason for this is this
is because my host file
it means, like, it's probably this host has
been cycled through. Yeah. And I no longer
have access to this host. But these other
ones are running. I should be coming to
active sessions. You can see it's sort of
like
all these sessions are firing up.
It's sort of going. And in our audit
log, you can see that
we have command execution from my Ansible bot.
I think what's also what's kinda interesting is
you see a
like, an SCP upload of, like, how it
sort of Ansible sort of works behind the
scenes. And so I guess this is sort
of the auditing
aspects of machine ID,
but you see it more or less worked,
but until I guess it didn't work for
these ones for our. And
so for
bigger
me my Ansible config.
See, my Ansible config is pretty standard.
I the host key is on. I have
inventory of host in my dot host file.
SSH connection is true.
And then my argument is I pick
the information from this machine ID SSH config.
And we have this command that will, like,
populate this for you.
So if I
You can see I have you know, this
is sort of my s s like, this
looks very familiar for people who have a,
like, dot SSH. Yeah.
And in inside of here, we have sort
of the
the key, the SSH certificates, SSH cert,
and then we also create this SSH config
for you.
And this SSH config sort of does the
plumbing to know, like, okay. Under the hood,
it's connecting to these hosts with these identity
files. It's running these commands. It's going over
port
thirty twenty three,
and you don't need to edit this at
all.
So that's the SSH config.
Let me just show you the hosts file.
And then you see my host is just
a list of all of my nodes,
which are the same nodes here based on
host name
plus
the cluster name of my cluster, which is
Teleport nine.
And I think some
of these were disconnected. That's why the host
name wasn't able to connect. But that's sort
of the configuration and sort of setup. I'll
just kinda, like, pause there for
Yeah. I wanna make sure I your thoughts.
I understand what's happening here. Right? So this
this is a AWS EC two virtual machine
just running
some Linux operating system.
Is there a Teleport agent running on this
machine?
There is a Teleport agent which you know,
I'm in a Teleport session, but there is
also
a Keybot service. Right. Okay.
And so this is sort of
very familiar for people who are used to
sort of Teleport.
You know, we have a, like, T bot
start. We have a config that I can
show you. It's using the IEM join method.
And then you can see
the renewal interval is every twenty minutes.
And so in the background,
this is connecting and talking to Teleport. In
each twenty minutes, it just issues new certificates,
which in the background, AMS will use.
Okay. If this TPO service is offline
for more than twenty minutes, will it fail
to rejoin?
Is that what the certificate rotation means?
Yeah. Alright. Okay. So as long as it's
online and happy, it's gonna continue to rotate
the service.
Then there is the so Azure was using
an SSH config. So
what's the command that I need to run
to be able to generate that for?
There is
let's go to
our docs.
So there is t bot init.
And init has some, yeah,
also useful commands for, like, ACLs and writing
permissions for which
uses the owner and when to initiate it.
So
I think we have examples here with file
permissions or with ACLs,
Let's say for the Jenkins example,
use if you're running it as, like, a
root user, but you can also want to
make it to the owner of Jenkins Jenkins,
we have these instructions here, and that'll sort
of configure your files
correctly.
And then once you run t
t bot start,
this will just go about and
configure everything for you.
I think the one other addition which actually
is probably missing here is it's based upon
your
t bot config.
And currently, this kind so configs is SSH
client.
You can get TLS certificates.
And as we add databases and other additions,
you can just sort of edit
the YAML file to get those other certificates
for you.
Right. Okay.
I think I understand that. So I'm thinking
about then
if I were setting this up for myself,
I spent up an EC two instance, I
installed Teleport.
What does that T port? Does T bot
need configured
besides the I'm stuff that we put this,
like does that need to add join token?
Does it need to add certificate?
Yes. It needs
okay. So we have
the first thing you need to do is
add a, like, a user.
And so this is, like, token based. The
IAM method, you create, like, a new token,
and this is kinda what I was saying.
You restrict it to
AWS
on
for access
and give it a name. And then when
you enroll the token, you sort of do
t boss add, and then that's sort of
the same flow as,
t cuddle,
Teleport sort of add a node.
And then it's the same flow of starting
machine ID.
And, yeah, then there's, like, other sort of
debug commands here for
making sure that you have access.
Cool.
Awesome.
I like that.
Is there anything else for tea bot? And
I think I well, let's just run my
we have the let's run the
in the playbook again.
And, actually, so you noticed
in my current demo, I just have hardcoded
host
file.
And we have instructions here on sort of
how to generate the host file in our
Ansible guide.
In this case, we use, like, TSH to
list,
and then we just add this to a
host file. This should be something in which,
like, we would like to make a small
program that will just talk to the Teleport
API to generate this host file for you,
but this is sort of just a example.
And this is why the host file was
sort of out of date with Teleport because
I've, you know, been firing up my cluster
up and down.
So this would be, like, another area in
which you might wanna automate. The T bot
daemon could just, like, load an eBPF program
to do this dynamically rather than actually modifying
the host file. I think that would be
pretty pretty cool.
Yeah. Then that's also, the same inventory of
Teleport.
You know,
you'd wanna also, like, you know, create
different
like, use our labels based for RBAC. And,
actually, if you come to RBAC,
they do create these, like, automatically generated
rows,
which will show you what
labels you can get access to, which under
the hood, which roles does it impersonate,
and what resources does it have access to.
And so it has access to the certificate
authority, but it can't read any secrets.
And there has been lots of work done
around the security of
these certificates and tokens.
And I think that's sort of one core
focus that we've worked with our customers is
just that if someone was to get access
to a
certificate,
one,
you have the ability to lock these
bots pretty easily.
You can make quotation easier.
And there's sort of some other stuff behind
the scenes we've done to really sort of
secure it. So
definitely,
it's relatively easy for Ansible, but I think
the most value comes from people who are
very sort of conscious and concerned of these
different sort of robots. Ants like, Ansible can,
like, touch all of your systems. And Yeah.
If someone gets access to those, like, public
private keys,
you could be in some trouble.
Yeah. Definitely. Like, I mean, I've lost count
of the amount of times in my career
that I've generated that, you know, SSH key
gen.
And then that just that's just been a
key I've used forever for the lifetime of
a project to
do any automation whatsoever.
And then Yeah. So we also have, like,
the audit log of
certificates issued,
and I think we sort of ran through
like, we've executed a command,
like,
what happened during these sort of sessions.
It's just sort of useful telemetry that
you wouldn't necessarily otherwise get of because all
the connections go through Teleport.
Yeah. And that's super important because we get
all of that auditing
stuff that we we just need for all
of these processes. Like, if we ever
wanna understand if a bot has gone a
bit rogue on us for whatever reason, then
we have all that information for the Teleport
Autologue. I think that's a really exciting addition
and I think it's gonna be really important.
And I'm gonna just say like the the
TLDR for the people watching this, that if
you have any automation that needs access to
a server or a database, then
machine ID is probably the way that you
wanna start building out that automation
in the future.
Yeah. And it's, you know, it's kinda like
a primitive. You build upon it based upon
how you want to configure
your services. You know, you could
run Tiva on the machine, or you could,
like, publish certificates and pull them through a
secret manager if you wanted to. You have
a range of options.
Does that mean I can have all of
my Kubernetes components authenticate
via automatically self rotating every twenty minutes x
five zero nine certificates? Is that something that
you see and maybe not today if it's
not possible or in the future?
Yeah. I think that will be coming
in, I think, Teleport nine one. I think
the first
today is just SSH, but we'll be adding
database and Kubernetes support.
Awesome. Very, very cool.
Alright. Anything else on machine ID that you
want to
I think that's it. I think the blog
post
goes into detail. Also, if you're interested, check
out our documentation.
Jenkins is another tool. We have an example
here of using Jenkins for
your Jenkins workers,
which is another example
of a
service that you might have around which you
haven't necessarily considered hardening
how you do deal with, like, SSH.
And once you sort of configure it and
set it up, you know, this is an
example in the Jenkins pipeline.
You can you know, if there is something
in your pipeline, you can just use Teleport
for it.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to clear that. I mean,
I don't use Jenkins as much as I
I used to. That's for sure. But
so You're a lucky man.
Yeah. I don't think everybody has that privilege.
There's a bit of a mechanical buzz there.
Can you
if you got, like, a cable for your
mic or something, just pull it out and
push it back in there. Okay. Is it
still there? Alright.
I think we're good.
Is it still there? Oh, yeah. It's still
busting.
Alright. How was that? You've angered it.
I made it worse?
Oh, no. Hold on.
Okay. Is that any better? Much better. That
is clean.
We're good. Okay. Perfect.
Okay.
Should we move on to the next features?
Are there any questions?
Yeah. If you are watching and you've got
yeah. I'll pop this back over to face
mode. Hold on. If
you're watching and you're curious
or have any questions about machine ID, drop
them into the comments, and Ben and I
will tackle them. But there is a lot
more in Teleport nine that we can
take a look at. So
what do you wanna tackle next?
I did have a list.
Okay. We've let's talk about Redis.
Alright. I know you've been dying to talk
about Redis, so let's talk about Redis.
I mean,
Salvatore
is no longer working on Redis, which I'm
very sad about, but many
small Redis comps with Salvatore was always
always fun. Do you wanna share
my screen again?
Yeah. Sure. Let's go. So
we are talking about Redis and Teleport nine,
I'm assuming Redis has now been added as
a supported database so that people can use
the
Teleport proxy to connect and secure the access
to it.
Correct. Yep. Awesome. So
Redis is, like, one of those interesting products.
And
I actually, like, hosted a RedisConf years ago,
and Salvatore was always, like
you know, he's quite an opinionated programmer. He's
like, you shouldn't really put Redis on the
Internet. It wasn't designed for that.
And
meaning that, you know, like, Redis should really
be in its own, like, private subnet. You're
like, you don't necessarily wanna, like, publicly expose
Redis,
which,
you know, I guess eventually people will do
things with your tool that you may not
necessarily expect. Oh, awesome. Have, like, basic,
yeah, password or but in Redis six, they
added support for TLS certificates
for authentication.
And
just in general, like, database support on Teleport,
you know, they're always, like, kinda like where
your crown jewels are, but also is most
likely to just be passing around a shared
password,
maybe for a team or a group. And
it runs into that same traditional problem of
if a team member leaves, like, did you
rotate the password? Like, pro probably not. It's
like that one ops person who seeded the
first RDS database, like, there's still a password
likely on, like, his notepad somewhere
that will get root access. And,
you know, Teleport,
you know, we started with the
large, like, SQL and NoSQL databases,
and then we're just sort of expanding our
suite of tools. So in Teleport nine, we
added Redis, Maribadb,
which is, you know, MySQL
variant
and
Microsoft
SQL Server,
which I haven't configured in this one because
I don't wanna necessarily go through the pain
of configuring Microsoft SQL Server.
Alright. So you didn't just add one database
to the Teleport line. You've added Redis,
Microsoft
SQL Server,
and MariaDB.
Yep. That's
cool. I know a lot of people that
prefer MariaDB
to buy SQL ever since Oracle had their
acquisition.
So it's good that
the people that that could have done that
route can also take advantage of these tools.
And I guess some people like Microsoft SQL
Server. I've never used it. I have no
I couldn't tell you a single damn thing
about Microsoft SQL Server, but it's cool that
people can secure it.
All I knew was when I looked at
our docs, it required going to, like, the
UI.
Or maybe not.
Yeah. If if I have to hook up
active directory to speak to my database, I
am already broken. This is not gonna happen.
Oh, yeah. When this popped up, I was
like, oh, I don't know if this is
for me. But it is we do have
people
and I'll probably configure this at some point
when I when I get the time
for it. But these are all of our
databases, you know, we support,
and we're just sort of slowly expanding them.
The team is cranking like crazy. So if
there's anyone that you'll
have a particular interest in, you know, you
can ping me. I know we've already had
requests for Redis,
like the AWS version of ElastiCache,
which is in process as well.
And then also just a note on Redis,
there's, like, two different instructions for if you're
using Redis cluster or
standalone Redis.
The instructions don't differ too much.
But once connected,
you'll get a sort of, like, a list
of your databases.
And everything for connecting and accessing your database
is actually done on the terminal. You know,
we have some instructions here to sort of
to tell you how to, like, log in
and get get credentials. But we assume most
database people have their own tooling either,
you know, it's like the Redis CLI or
it is like
GUI for Postgres.
And we also have instructions on how to
configure those GUI. So let's
log in.
And then I'm using my
SSH flow again.
I didn't have to log in again. That's
good.
I think you're okay. Maybe?
I think it's okay. There we are. So
we're in.
And, you know, you know, same sort of
flow, like,
for servers,
we have TSHLS,
TSH DBLS.
One thing you do need to do is
you need to log in with the database
user,
and this is almost like your principle in
the world of servers. So if you would
log in as like Ubuntu, it needs to
be sort of baked into your certificate. You
do the same thing for logging into
the database. So I have a
I actually think this user's different. I think
it's SRE team is my
name of my user.
And then I can just do TSH DB
connect
Redis.
And what's really interesting here, so this is
connected.
But if I do, like, ping,
not authenticated.
Redis does require you to also add a
password
auth
in addition to the TLS certificates, just the
way in which it works.
Don't know about that.
I think most of the ones, like, there's
always, a little quirk.
Let's say if you configure so you have
access to the database, but you also need
to map the user and the database together.
And so for people who are used to,
like, the Kubernetes and server flow, just be
aware of that extra mapping of a database
user. It normally differs per database just to
sort of put in your documentation.
Cool.
Can I ask you the hard question then?
So
with the introduction of machine ID
Teleport
now supported more and more databases,
I'm starting to have this
really weird idea
that even in my application code, instead of
configuring it to speak directly to my database
with a username and password or,
you know, forever certificates that I'm never gonna
rotate because I'm a terrible SRE.
Does
Teleport fit into that workflow or would that
just be really
silly?
And by that, I mean, if my back
ends application
used Teleport
and machine ID for
every connection, every request.
Is that a good thing? Should I be
should I be experimenting with that?
We
like, that is if you look at the
demo video for machine ID, that's sort of
what we led with. It's talking like a
microservice,
talking to your infrastructure.
Now I guess the question is, is it
a good thing?
We believe so, especially for, let's say, your
development
or, like, let's say, you will need to
do some local development against a staging database.
It's like a perfect use case.
For your production DB,
I'm not a % sure on, like, our
performance. You know, if everything has to go
through Teleport, what's the performance overhead? I asked
the team. They said it's kinda, like,
minimal
because once they sort of connected, it kinda
goes through, but it is like another
something else in the middle. But I guess
Teleport is not handling log. Connection pulling or
anything like that. I'm assuming that every request
is is spot up, accepted, responded, and then
shut back down.
I'm not a %
sure on the connection pooling and the performance
overhead, but we can I think this is
an area that we'll, like, keep exploring, and
this is definitely an area in which we
wanna, like, get you know, we wanna sort
of remove all passwords?
And passwords, we also see as, like, API
keys
for your databases
or
whatever sort of secrets you have.
Yeah. And so you
Sorry. You
can do it for, like, your microservice.
So instead
of
adding it
instead of using, like, hard coding a Postgres
or, like, Redis database, you just use the
certificates that you obtain, and then you can
sort of go about your connections. And one,
you know, like, who's accessing which database,
and you have the full sort of audit
log.
Yeah. I've kinda got this grand vision though
that
in my Kubernetes
cluster
is that every single backend service that needs
to speak to any other service could just
have a sidecar teleport
thing
that does the machine ID
and then works out if I'm allowed to
speak to Postgres or I'm allowed to speak
to Kafka or I'm allowed to speak to
Redis. And it just, like to the point
where I'd almost have, like, zero configuration
anymore to speak to a database. And I
think that would be pretty cool.
Yeah. And I've it it seems like what
you're showing me is kinda where it's heading,
and I think that's really exciting.
Yep. It's definitely
where we're heading.
And, hopefully, we'll have more demos over the
next coming months. Maybe this is a good
follow-up livestream.
Yeah. That seems like one of those questions
to you. Like,
that's not a road map, and I can't
really talk about that yet. So just shut
up, David.
No. It is not. It is in our
video.
I don't have a working example.
No. No. Sorry. I don't need to see.
I just I think,
you know, especially if, you know, I know
that the workload identity works with AWS,
but I'm like, could they pick up the
service account and verify that? And then they
know the pod with, like, the the the
downward API.
All of this could be baked in to
some sort of agent. And then all
of my requests to other databases and even
other services to another point could be handled
in this kind of secure audited
fashion.
And I've basically, what I'm saying is Teleport,
that's product has to be a service mesh.
I think that's where you're going now. So
we need we need we need t mesh.
Can we get t mesh?
We actually talk about why
machine ID isn't a service mesh in our
blog post?
I used to start paying more attention.
Let me see. Go here.
And what do we say? We have a
full
so we talk about like PKI and machine
ID.
And then we'll talk about service measures. Oh,
yeah. So like how we kind of like
fit in. This is like the official word.
Think our answers are still a bit vague.
So we say we're complementary. We sort of
work together with service meshes.
But like all these tools, you know, it's
always like building on top of other tools
and adding on top of it. Well, yeah.
Well And if you look at like Sorry.
Go ahead.
Oh, if you look at, like,
Kong or or Envoy, like, they have, like,
some basic certificate authority kinda, like, baked into
them, but you can provide your own certificates.
And so maybe this is sort of a
avenue for least for the, like, CA management
and RBAC is sort of how we support
the sort of service mesh solutions.
Well, yeah, I I was kind of about
to touch on that as well. Like, all
of these things pretty much, I think nine
times out of 10, they run their own
end cluster CA
as they handle automatic MTLS across services.
But I think they only work mostly for
HTTP traffic. I don't think it works with
the database
level layer,
or at least it doesn't have that,
I guess it's L7 awareness.
I gotta have to try to remember my
OSI layers, but I think L7 is application
though, right? It
would be cool, yeah. I could see a
future, I guess, where Selium and STO,
Linkerd, etcetera,
maybe start to rely on Teleport
as
a CA and be able to pass those
around, bake them in more levels of an
awareness and application handling, be like, oh, you
know, this pod is now trying to speak
to Postgres. We're gonna give it the right
certificate to go and authenticate against that. I
don't know. This is just grand ideas. I'm
I'm it just makes me excited to see
what Teleport does in the next six months
and the next two releases because I'm pretty
sure you guys have got a lot in
your heads and a lot of people with
great ideas too. Yeah.
Definitely, we'll be exploring
more avenues. So, like, we just closed the
loop on Redis.
Oh, yeah. That's right. We were doing a
Redis demo.
I got And then you can see we
have oh, you can see I typed Redis
info wrong.
You can say, like, who executed which query
and which database. And I think this is,
like, the core, you know, Teleport's bread and
butter. It's like,
you have these shared logins for accessing services.
It's the SRE team, and you know it's,
like, tied to my identity as
an error in accessing
this host, doing whatever, like, debugging commands,
which is that easy sort of compliance check.
Cool.
Alright.
What is next on my list? Okay. So
another one that's pretty exciting, but I tried
it before this and it didn't work. So
is our access requests,
and
we can try it now. But I had
this book post today, which is why the
four eyes principle is critical for access. It's
a bit of a long ramble about
basically how, like, the majority of our
Teleport has gone from
is there's different technology solutions. So we have
like our session recording,
but there's ways around our session recording because
there's problems with restricted shells. And so we
talked about why we created enhanced EPPF
session enhanced session recording,
which is great, but it also doesn't necessarily
stop everything. So, like, you can't really like,
you can turn off SCP, but there's still
ways in which you can, like, exfiltrate data.
And we there's another good blog post here
about restricted shells.
And the long
winded
conclusion is, like, ultimately, you sort of need
more individuals and humans to be on a
session to either moderate it or see what's
happening.
She
Coinbase back in the day, I guess they
don't do this now. They don't now they're
globally remote, they had, like, a SSH room
with a drop cam in which Coinbase would
do all of their SSH activity, and that
was the only way in which you get
access to certain hosts.
And and to some degree,
you know, with
shared sessions,
which I guess you use for your clustered,
you anyone can kinda join them or there's,
like, some limited, But you can now set,
like, our back to require certain roles to
join a session for them to join. So
there's an example Kubernetes role here in which
you need to be a sec ops role
and an audit role to join a session.
And I can try the
demo gods
here.
I mean, this Lisa was my demo user.
Also a great programmer
at Teleport.
Log in.
And then this is, you know, like the
standard flow for
thing,
keep configs.
I have a
okay. So
they should I think I just filed a
bug this morning. Like, there should be a
message here saying, like, this session is sort
of hanging right now. And if I come
to the audit log, you can see that
Lisa has made a request to access a
Kubernetes cluster
for, like, a kubectl exec and is waiting
for someone
to approve it.
And until someone else joins this session, it
would just sort of hang.
And that other party or multiple parties have
the ability to also terminate the session as
well,
and this is sort of our Kubernetes moderated
sessions.
Cool.
But I it's a bit difficult to demo
because I also need to hang up another
Yeah. To have a second login. Join. And
yeah.
And I think I can't, like, exit this
either. I think there's, another bug, though.
More of the bugs should be gone for
moderated sessions.
Awesome. Yeah. That would be a cool feature
as well.
I've been asked while you're on the audit
page. I've been asked what is the EI
field of the audit log?
Field,
but maybe,
you know.
I actually don't know what the e I
field is. That's a great question.
I think it's always zero.
I can get back to you. Yeah. Always
zero.
Unfortunately,
we don't know.
We'll
we'll work it out. We'll leave a comment
on the video, and we'll tweet something about
it. But, yeah, I'm curious about that.
Alright. Then last up.
Wait. There's more? There's
more. There's always more, Dave. You should know.
It's fun for the Seven
for Redis. Just
throwing that out there. So e I for
Redis was seven.
For Redis?
Sorry. You you can't get over your demo.
I
can track that though.
So
one of the other additions, which actually I
think is pretty cool, we didn't really talk
about this much, me edit my role,
is we added
prior MFA.
So we've added this feature that lets you
add other
let me just check that this this is
right. I could just
I just see it over and see what
happens.
I think it doesn't
okay. Require MFA is not right. Okay. So
added to the per session MFA,
and you can set
required MFA sessions.
And so each time you start a session,
you are required to present a hardware token
or a software token.
And we added this support for Windows
access and
what is it? Require.
Require session MFA.
And so this lets you add an additional
second factor. So in my account settings, I
have a YubiKey, and you can add multiple
hardware tokens. Yeah. And this sort of prevents
like, let's say someone gets access to your
GitHub account.
If you acquire MFA,
you know, they would also need access to,
like, a hardware token in addition to whatever
to get access. Yep.
I think I need to log out back
in again. Useful for production databases, I would
imagine.
Yes.
And there's actually one
open issue that we're making, like, per like,
it's currently per road,
and we'll plan to make, like, per label
to just give you a bit more flexibility.
Okay.
But we added this let's say if I
come into this domain controller.
Okay. Without the clipboard. And it's gonna ask
me to verify my identity,
which means I need to tap my
token,
and it logs me into my
domain controller. You can see that clipboard sharing
is enabled. It's recording.
I don't know if you spend much time
in
main controllers.
I try not to. But no. You try
not to.
But,
you know, this
was
like, desktop access was adding in Teleport
eight, but we've sort of rounded it out
so the recording is a big addition along
with our
clipboard.
So let me just close this.
Let me just disconnect.
And now we have the same
session recording and playback for
desktop sessions as well.
Very cool. So you can know what's happening,
which is
pretty interesting. Like, the most basic level of
RDP is like a tile of PNGs.
And
actually, I have another, like, livestream with the
developer. This is pretty interesting sort of background.
Like, we built it from scratch, our sort
of RDP protocol support.
And so if people who are interested especially
in, like, we built it with Rust. It's
like an interesting sort of tech deep dive
and sorts of interesting tech problems with adding
desktop support.
60 PNGs per second just being saved. Is
that what it is?
Yeah. I think it's like
cut, like, tiled.
And you actually you can't stop and play
it due to like the stream of PNGs.
We're also looking like different video formats. So
we're
sort of, I guess, trying to get feedback
about where we should sort of take this
session player next.
But for people who
sort of upgrading their, like, Windows desktop access,
lots of exciting
sort of updates and improvements for them. Sweet.
Awesome. Well, I'm glad I'm Alright. Working on
session recording for desktop sessions,
and other people get to do that because
so while you were also saying that, I
looked up the e I thing.
Are you curious?
I'm curious. Yeah. It's event index. So the
zero is every time you open a new
session, and then every subsequent command,
e I will be incremented by one so
that you have an order for the commands
executed,
which is why register seven because you did
the
ping pong earlier, and then you did an
off, and then you did a and
so forth. So
that's it. Easy with you. Alright. That's it.
Yeah. It's good idea. Event index. So I
know there's a lot here in this version.
If anyone has any questions for, like, machine
ID or they wanna try it out,
I know I'll be hitting you up, David,
for when we add our database support.
Sort of Kubernetes services
will be an exciting area for exploration.
Yeah. Definitely. It's something I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna start playing with machine ID now
and and see how I can incorporate it
into my my production infrastructure. I have a
lot of automation
that works. So
and I am very bad for long lived
hard coded tokens. So I'm gonna see if
I can remove a lot of this from
my workflow.
I'll definitely
I'm I'm sure I'm gonna be in touch
on Slack, like, help.
Yeah. If anyone wants to join, here's our
link to our Slack room.
And, yeah, we'll it's sort of growing, and
we're always sort of happy to help. And
then if there's any bugs, you know, we're
like an open call, open source company. You
can sort of come in here and
sort of see what's happening. And then the
last thing is we talked about, like, roadmap
and supports.
We have our upcoming releases page sort of
describes,
you know,
Kubernetes
and database access support for machine ID.
We have a Teleport Terminal, which is gonna
be an exciting addition in 09/2002.
More to come on that. What's the Teleport
Terminal?
My interest is peak. Tell me. Me. Tell
me. It's one for another
webinar. Keep that for a different session.
But, yeah, you can see we're starting Cassandra
and Snowflake support
and going GA. So lots of stuff sort
of happening here.
So, yeah, just we're sort of available and
here to chat.
Alright. Well, we'll give everybody a couple of
minutes. So if you have any questions, I'll
drop them into the comments now. I see
we've got one from you, Evan Ash, so
we'll tackle that first. But if anyone else
has any questions, let us know, and we'll
tackle that.
Asks,
does Teleport provide access controls to streaming services
like RabbitMQ
as well?
So are do you plan on supporting Rabbit,
Kafka,
Redpanda,
anything like that?
I'm not too sure, actually. I'll
have to talk to Roman. I kinda forget
what the auth
protocol is for
Rabbit and Kafka. It's been a while since
I've been on the sharp end of it.
I think Kafka by default is
nothing.
But you can configure it for x five
zero nine. So this it may work well.
RabbitMQ,
I'm not that familiar with anymore. I haven't
touched it in in many years. So I'm
not sure what the authentication is like there.
Yeah. It's definitely something that we can look
into. Like, open a GitHub issue, we can
sort of dive into it. I guess the
idea being if it's x five zero nine,
then Teleport can support it. And it's just
a matter of how many people want it
and upvoting all these issues. Right? Yeah. Pretty
much.
Alright. So, I've been asked, go check for
RabbitMQ or Kafka issue, whatever one you're looking
for.
If it's not there, start it.
Thank you for your question.
Oh, well. We'll we'll give everyone just one
more minute.
How's your how's your day going, Ben? Is
it morning or evening for you? It's the
morning here. Just getting started. It's the accent
that throws me off. I'm always like, he's
right next to me, but he's not. I
know.
Just getting started.
Done my blog post for the day. I've
done my livestream, so might take a little
break. Just important to step away from your
computer. Always. Well, not from me. I'm looking
outside. It's absolutely heaving down the rain. So
I might just end up staying at my
office and not leaving. It's
gonna be 24 degrees today out here. So
Where are you again?
I'm in Oakland. Oakland. There we go. I
Yeah. You're always gonna get a good weather
over there. Right?
Yeah.
Do you ever miss the British weather?
No. I don't miss the British weather. Alright.
I don't think we're Oh, by the way,
think last thing, are you going to KubeCon?
I am going to KubeCon. Are you going
to KubeCon?
I won't be going to KubeCon, but we'll
have a big team there.
So if the last six people on the
stream will be going to KubeCon, I know
you have some exciting t shirts too,
and
we will have lots of swag. So definitely
swing by the booth for
a chat or a demo with some of
our team. Awesome. Well, maybe I'll see you
at KubeCon. It's Detroit in North America, right,
at the in October? Yeah. I think I'll
likely be in Detroit.
Cool. Sweet.
Alright. Well, Ben, you for joining me. It's
always a pleasure. I'm looking forward to doing
more experiments and demos with you, especially
as we roll out more Teleport features. And
I I'm definitely gonna hit you up for
Teleport Terminal and see what that is. Plus
the fun things to play with. But thank
you again. Have a great day, and I'll
speak to you soon. Bye.